tu ne peux rien faire d'autre que ce que
Dieu autorise
tu lui autorisé ça
père Gabriel est morte
le soir du 4 juin
vous avez procédé à un exorciste
elle n'était pas possible
elle souffrait de troubles mentaux
qu'est-ce que vous me voulez
nous n'avons pas fini de vous interroger
père à morte
adressez-vous à mon patron
le pape
il y a un cas ok votre attention
l'enfant a-t-il subi un traumatisme il a
vu son père se fait empaler vous pouvez
compter sur moi
que veux-tu réponds-moi toi je suis ton
pire cauchemar mon cauchemar
c'est que la France soit championne du
monde arrête de te cacher derrière tes
petites blagues
c'est
le saut du Vatican
l'église avait déjà combattu ce démon et
le Vatican a étouffé
et tu es tombé dans le piège
tu ne peux rien faire d'autre que ce que
Dieu autorise
il l'a autorisé ça
imaginez ce qui se passerait si l'âme de
l'exorciste du pape était possédé par le
diable qui vous défendrait
ma foi
n'a besoin d'aucune défense
[Applaudissements]